I'm gonna put you on the spot for a
second were you a fan of his growing up
did you ever have a crush on him One
Tree Hill
absolutely yeah chad michael murray and
francesca eastwood co-star in outlaws
and angels but before making movie magic
together Clint's now 22 year old
daughter admits she was crushing on jad
over ten years ago
I think was exciting I mean I think I
remember going to this Cinderella story
I was a little girl yeah and so and I
remember yeah I mean that was just I
think I was about 11 or 12 and Julie got
a crush on him no I didn't meet him then
but when you're going in and we were
working on a project that's so intense
and that you need to be so focused I
very much was Florence from day one so
yeah because I never picked that up for
a second their new movie hits theaters
and VOD on July 15th
but Chad still has a place in his heart
for the small screen series that made
him a star nice hands nice legs there's
a One Tree Hill reunion coming up I'm
totally excited that's amazing the way
that this show has really created a life
and and and just reached and touched so
many people and so it's an honor at the
end of the day and it was a part of my
life so then if the opportunity arose to
return to Tree Hill on a small screen
big screen he would make me do it there
would be a lot of question marks for me
it would be what is the content what is
the material and so if it was gonna come
into a world that was very different and
just stir up the world yeah I'd love to
give it a look I'm sorry very own new
clothing line it's every morning I'm
Brad Brad well I bet spring queen season
two I've really back are you kidding me
well first off I love Glenn Glenn's one
of my good buddies the guy's awesome I'm
actually a scream queens fan we're gonna
admit it I watch it on let's go forgot a
DVR and so I'm hoping that Brad rad
welcomes and comes back because I was
fun it's a great environment it's a lot
of fun so it
great to go by